exactly this is how people in rwanda's
Western Province start their day
attempting to save whatever they can
from their ruined homes
Muddy Waters from Tuesday night's
Landslide still flow through rubabu
district one of the hottest hit areas
those who managed to escape the Deluge
described what they experienced
I was in bed suddenly my house moved and
I thought it was the wind mixed with
rain just as I was thinking what to do
the water was gone and the walls of my
house were destroyed I was saved by a
neighbor and ran with my children
the rain was coming down heavily Through
the Windows I saw a neighbor house
falling down and the old man living in
it died all of a sudden the water and
the river attacked us everywhere and the
houses fell down one by one and we fled
rescue crews are having a hard time
getting to those most affected blocked
main roads severely hampering rescue
efforts
president Paul kagame tweeted his
condolences saying his government will
do everything within its means to assist
the governor of the western Province
where most of the deaths are being
reported scissors officials have
prioritized reaching damaged houses to
make sure no one is trapped
those hoping for some relief from the
downpours will have to wait
the Rwanda meteorology agency is warning
more rain is to come